the media queries used most often for
responsive web design our min width and
max width max width rules are applied
anytime the viewport width is less than
the value specified for example max
width 500 pixels is matched when the
viewport is 500 pixels or less it's also
possible to create queries based on min
device width or max device width but
this is strongly discouraged the
difference is subtle but very important
min width is based on the size of the
browser window whereas min device width
is based on the size of the screen
in addition using device width can
prevent content from adapting on
desktops or other devices that allow the
windows to be resized because the query
is based on the actual device size not
the browser window the other reason some
browsers the legacy Android browser may
report the wrong value